it is an absolute honor to welcome
robert f kennedy jr to the stage he's
part of america's most famous political
dynasty commanding an audience in a way
his uncle jfk once might have
this is an anti-vaccine mandate rally
but many in this crowd hold extreme and
scientifically unproven views about the
covid19 vaccine and robert f kennedy jr
is encouraging them
since the pandemic began visitors to his
charity website have exploded their
revenue more than doubled in 2020 to 6.8
million dollars
some people would say
you're profiting from a public health
crisis here what do you say to that i
would say that pfizer is the one if
you're worried about somebody
profiting from a public health crisis
you should be investigating pfizer you
should be investigating moderna if we
just put the pharmaceutical companies
and their profits to one side
is your charity making money as a result
of this pandemic are you taking more
money from the charity since the the
pandemic has has begun in salary am i
personally yeah
i i've given all of my book profits
to the charities so this uh
this
has cost me it is the opposite of
profits for me personally because you
have this enormous star power and your
name that you're lending legitimacy to
things that aren't scientifically proven
the the centre for disease control says
you're 14 times less likely to die from
covid if you have the vaccine are you
putting people's lives on me
the scientific society that chosen no
we are saving people's lives and we're
saving democracy because children should
not be getting this magazine should
where 99 of the people hooked up to
ventilators struggling to breathe are
unvaccinated
accidentally
they've not had they've not had a job
kind of actually
number one number two it's a personal
choice
lissette traveled 13 hours on a coach to
be here she doesn't consider herself
anti-vaxx but will not get the covered
vaccine
here in her home state of kentucky 45 of
people aren't fully vaccinated do you
actually think that more people
hold the views that you have than maybe
is commonly known yeah i think more
people do
um but i think people just
um
are just keeping it to themselves
it's sort of like when the elections for
trump and whoever buy it there were a
lot of undercover trump supporters
i think more people
um
believe
that
they're just going to wait and see they
don't they're not really believing the
the mainstream media or what the cdc or
what fauci or fda or who experience
vaccine misinformation is infecting
america and it's spreading online what's
remarkable about the anti-vaccine
industry and it is an industry is that
only a small number
of very organized very sophisticated
very determined bad actors control the
vast majority of the misinformation that
you see out there the push to get
america vaccinated is vital but they're
fighting an undercurrent of
misinformation it's a well-funded and
well-organized movement and it's
dividing this country martha kellner sky
news kentucky